thank you very much fantastic to see so
many people here we will launch into our
discussion in just a few moments time
let me remind us all though first of all
about what we are discussing is has the
trump presidency caused or is it causing
irreparable damage to America the dis
United States the title that goes before
that and there's no question that that
bit at least that disunited bit is
obviously true the second bit well you
can argue about and we will and of
course you will have the opportunity as
well to argue an answer questions in a
second there is no question at all that
being President of the United States as
Donald Trump has discovered is quite a
difficult job when I was there Obama was
elected and all the headlines have
rather pedantic newspaper headlines in
the US they so the New York Times was
Obama elected president the new The
Washington Post was President Obama it's
true etc etc one newspaper I thought
caught the essential ambivalence of the
moment and that was the onion the
satirical newspaper and their headline
read black man given nation's worst job
and it kind of turned out like that
didn't it and it kind of does and of
course what Trump to an extent has
discovered is that you can't do as
president all those things you hoped to
do when you came to office and I suspect
some of our panelists and I suspect some
of you might say well that's a damn good
thing to but we were one of the things
we are going to be discussing is the
extent to which I guess that is still
the case the other thing that I think
might well come up and is so relevant
and interesting is the personality and
the personal behavior of people who
become president which let's face it has
not always in the past been saintly and
I look back again actually to the way in
which that can be diffused sometimes by
personalities and by an individual sense
that actually whatever people believe
about the world they still have a
respect for the process and w bush I was
BBC correspondent for a bit of time when
he was there let us face it also
somewhat criticized by some for some of
the things he did and yet he had that
incredible sense behind the scenes that
he did except that you as a reporter had
the right to be doing what you did I
remember an interview with him you know
quite combat it at the end it said you
get to the end of the interview how was
that for you did you like it no
wonderful thank you very much for doing
this ready before you go do you want to
see the Oval Office I'd love to see
there do you want to see the Rose Garden
you want to see the library corridor
again I found myself saying to the
president the United States look I'm
terribly sorry but I got have got to be
somewhere else and that of course is one
of the big differences with Donald Trump
who would not be doing that conducted
tour I suspect for John so Paul the
current BBC corresponded
many others indeed only today has been
talking about withdrawing the
credentials of people who were there so
all of those things may or may not come
out but I thought I'd sort of set the
scene at least from the perspective of
someone who hasn't been reporting in
America for some time but certainly did
and with great affection actually for
quite a lot of time and my youngest
daughter is a US citizen and I'm very
happy that that's the case so let me
introduce then our guest very briefly
and I'll do it as it were from my
extreme right towards me but don't read
anything into that Mark Lilla professor
of humanities at Columbia University his
New York Times op-ed of November 2016
which was called the end of identity
liberalism was the newspapers most read
political op-ed of the year and he's
expanded that argument into a book and
the title of the book is the once and
future liberal after identity politics
and one of the things we will be getting
to is is what happens after Trump or how
Trump is toppled and and I think mark
will have particularly interesting
things to say about that Lionel Shriver
author of twelve novels the man
doubles a family 20 29 to 20 47 is a
best-seller but so of course is we need
to talk about Kevin she's a prolific
journalist she's just published a
novella and a story collection called
property Bryan class next to her is a
fellow in global politics at the London
School of Economics
he's also Washington Post columnist and
an author in his book the despots
apprentice Donald Trump's attack on
democracy slightly reveals I think it's
fair to say what he thinks anyway that's
a very minor argument and he will be
talking about that and more widely as
well and Ronan Farrow next to me
investigative journalist writes for The
New Yorker makes documentaries now for
HBO he won this year's Pulitzer Prize
gold medal for public service for
exposing the alleged sexual predations
of Harvey Weinstein he's just published
his first book which is called war on
peace the end of diplomacy and the
decline of American influence which I
guess also slightly anyway let me put a
quick question to all of you and it's a
question actually about what happened
the night that Donald Trump was elected
where were you how did you find out
about it what did it mean to you when it
happened Lionel Shriver it wasn't night
for me I was in Hong Kong and I was
getting a flight to Singapore and when I
got on the plane
everything was fine I checked all the
swing states were still in play there
was just a little funny business with
Florida didn't concern me and
frustratingly I got on one of those old
points that didn't have any Wi-Fi and I
was completely surrounded by Chinese
people so finally the plane landed I was
a little fidgety because I wanted to get
this over with and I of course knew who
was going to win
and when the plane landed everyone took
out their phones but I couldn't tell
anything and the guy sitting next to me
said and you knew I was I was more
concerned but I didn't find out until
walking all the way down the corridor
and finally I found a BBC TV screen on
and that was that was the moment and it
went across the the crawl Donald J Trump
elected president of the United States
and I honestly embarrassed myself
because I stopped stone-cold and it was
like thirty feet away and I said what
[Laughter]
Brian so I had a sort of unusual
experience I was over here it was about
4:30 in the morning I guess when I
realized I was on LBC they had overnight
coverage and it was a very jarring
moment for me because I had received a
text right before I was going on air
from one of my friends who had gotten
the news that Trump was elected and she
had just given birth to a newborn and
her husband was Hispanic and she was
saying she was going to change his
surname to her surname because she
didn't she didn't want to have him grow
up in a world in which that would be a
disadvantage and clearly the Trump
election would would be that in her mind
and then I'm getting ready to go on and
Nigel Faraj called in and boasted about
how he'd made a pretty penny gambling
and betting on Trump and it was just
this massive amount of I guess it was
just severe disappointment in the
country that I have defended so many
times to Brits because I've lived over
here for seven years and when you live
abroad as an American you end up being
an apologist for your country and it was
this moment where
it just really hit me hard because it
was like the country that I had said was
there was not there and that's that's
what relieved I mean I just I walked out
of the studio it started pouring rain
and I was in a suits and I just dripped
all the way home
and I there must be a German word for
feeling exactly how you look and that
was probably what it was yeah it'll be
very long - yeah well a half hour before
the results were announced I was sitting
on the roof of a hotel in midtown
Manhattan it was not a very cold day and
I was there with some elegant French
journalists and we were all talking an
impeccable French about how it was
absolutely impossible that he would win
c'est pas possible and then the results
came in but I have to say my first
reaction after that and I had I bet it
was shared by everyone on the stage here
was I really don't know my country I
thought I knew it the range of people
from the right and the left I have
friends on both sides but in some deep
sense I no longer knew my country and
that meant that I had some work ahead of
me right story I went home to
Connecticut where my mom lives on a
sprawling rundown farm with a bunch of
chickens and I was way outside of the
political zeitgeist and you know I wish
I could say that he was elected and
there was a great squawking of the hens
it really you know it happened and I
watched you know my various family
members tear their hair out and gnash
their teeth and I felt very
dispassionate and distant from the whole
thing I mean the I suppose the emotional
resonance of it came from the calls I
began getting from you know women
immigrants who care about immigration
issues from people of color from people
of all sorts of sexual orientations who
all felt that this was a personal rebuke
and I think like what you just said
that they sort of no longer knew their
country and as it turns out those
reactions fed directly into everything
that we've seen on sexual assault
reporting since then I think that this
was a moment of frustration that
contributed to the breaking of the dam
let us see that let us explore now the
extent to which all those fears have or
have not come true and I want to start
with the foreigner but the given that it
is so much in the news and obviously
with their arm but also with with North
Korea the extent to which Trump abroad
has been a genuine and irreconcilable as
it were break with the past
Ronan kick us off with your sense of of
what he's done so far and the effect
that the impact that has had in this
book that you mentioned that I've just
written which I'll be relentlessly
plugging for all you fine folks tonight
Henry Kissinger says an interesting
thing is one of the many secretaries of
state all of the former secretaries went
on the record for this book and you know
I'm very careful to portray the ways in
which he is complicated and difficult
and one of the frank statements he makes
is about the lack of respect for
expertise in history in American culture
right now and I think the election of
Donald Trump flows directly from that he
gave this incredible quote talking about
Richard Holbrooke one of the sort of
last great diplomats of the modern era
who brokered peace in Bosnia and was a
mentor of mine and a character in this
book and he described you know the
fights that Richard Holbrooke had with
the Obama administration and said you
know the Obama administration like many
incoming presidencies had little time
for historical context and then he said
and you know his deep Bavarian rasps or
booming from across the eons for
directly from The Oval Office of the
Nixon administration you know it is one
great American mistake that you can
always make some new innovation you know
that that he felt it was a myth that we
have cultivated as a nation but you can
always try something new and different
and yeah it's part of the it's part of
who you are it's right I mean that's why
we split from all
fine folks yeah but but I think that it
has perhaps gone to an extreme where
it's creating a moment of reckoning and
we see that in the destruction of the
State Department and the wholesale
purging of all of the experts that could
guide us through this moment whatever
get to others just on that you you make
the point in your book that yes it has
been decimated under Trump but actually
the the the decimation had already
started all the disregard for the State
Department had started and it was really
more 911 than Trump that did that well
this is a new extreme and we've never
seen the sort of flagrant wholesale
disregard for the culture of expertise
that we're currently seeing and the
attendant firings and the empty
ambassadorships around the world but
you're absolutely right that there is
precedent for it specifically after 9/11
that was an inflection point where
foreign policy became much more
militarized and you know Brian could
also speak to that but even before then
the Clinton administration had a similar
kind of sentiment of a turn inward and a
pandering to isolationists it's the
economy stupid was the mantra that James
Carville brought to the table and the
result of that was that we gutted the
State Department then and it had very
disastrous results closed a lot of
embassies closed to government agencies
it really set us up for a world of
declining diplomacy after 9/11 the point
that what a pro Trump person would say
about specifically North Korea is you
drift and you're predictable as an
American president whether it's Bush or
whether it's Obama and you do your best
and you try things with the Chinese and
actually nothing much works and things
get gradually worse and worse with Trump
for all that it's dangerous it's also
potentially effective in a way that they
couldn't be does anyone at least
understand that argument I understand
that argument
but I mean my concern we're gonna just
look at North Korea is that if it's
apparent to all of us
our president is a fool then it is
glaringly apparent to world leaders
across the world also and I you know
however much of a weirdo kim jong hoon
is he's not an idiot
and he I believe he thinks he can
manipulate Donald Trump he probably can
and he probably is and I you know I'm
happy to be proved wrong but all I see
from a distance is the North Korean
leadership doing what it has done before
and it will try to do a deal and we'll
get lots of goodies it will get oil
it'll get food it'll get concessions
with the South they'll get you know
friendly stuff going on and and anything
that he claims to sacrifice he will take
back I'm he'll he'll renege on the deal
he's done it before and I think one of
the things that also needs to be said is
that the the North Korea deal obviously
I mean we're all hoping that it goes
better than expected or that finally
this is the time as a breakthrough but
at the same time at what cost is is
happening and the answer is at the cost
of our allies and I think that's really
important is that in a sort of twofold
way one is that allies look at Trump and
they don't see their values reflected
and the other is that Trump is harsher
on American allies including the UK and
its leaders than he is on traditional
adversaries he's been more negative in
statements about Teresa Maher Angela
Merkel than he has about President Xi of
China or even Putin in his public
statements and you see this I mean
there's hard data to back this up even
if it's preliminary but six months into
Trump's time in office there was a Pew
Research survey that was done about
confidence in US leadership it was also
done at the end of Obama's time in
office and the difference was down
confidence was down from Obama to trump
seventy five percent in Germany 71
percent in South Korea seventy percent
in France 57 percent in the UK and 54
percent in Japan now if we're gonna get
anything done in America in American
diplomacy for the foreseeable future we
need those allies and that did manage to
we've had the biggest strategic
catastrophe I'm sorry by the way I'm
taking a trump line this is not the BBC
speaking here but but you know
well we have had in Syria and put aside
if you can for a second that the
suffering of the Syrian people but we
have had the greatest strategic
catastrophe for the West since the
Second World War and that happened on
the watch of people who were linked to
allies keen on diplomacy etc it's a no I
think the focus on Kim and on Korea is
all wrong it's just it's dramatic
because of these two personalities but
the big change is the realignment that
will take place because of Trump in the
Middle East that you will have a new
axis of Sunni powers with Israel led by
Saudi Arabia on the Sunni side against
Iran and smaller Shia States so it's
possible for someone like Trump to be
consequential person without having done
very much actually simply by making it
clear to the Likud niks where he stands
on this and things start to fall
together and it's in situations like
this where our lack of historical
knowledge and our lack of cultural depth
will really show because a lot is going
to happen very quickly and it's
precisely in moments like that where you
need people who just know stuff who know
exactly what is happening on the ground
in each of these places who doesn't make
an amalgam of all the Arab states or saw
the Sunni states but who knows what's
going on there and all we have are empty
desks and that's my chief concern when
you talk about this prospect of
leader-to-leader meetings in the North
Korea process we have correctly as a
nation turned down that opportunity
before there have been the same lies
before there have been concessions made
that then we're not lived up to and
there is a very real risk going into
those kinds of conversations that you
get played this is one of the wiliest
and slipperiest diplomatic opponents
that we have ever faced and the problem
is if you don't have the kinds of
experts that we were just talking about
if you don't have the people who say hey
here are the pressure points in this
region here are the lies they've told
before here
concessions not to make and the coded
language not to stumble into you you do
end up getting played very likely so
time will tell if it works but we are
flying blind in a way we don't have to
be right now right yeah it's fun to add
one other thing I mean I think there's
also this aspect where things can be bad
as you said with Syria certainly I mean
it was a disaster
but they could also be worse right and I
think we don't see the disasters that
were averted by people who actually know
what they're doing in global politics we
also might have situations that look
like they're improving under Trump and
David Frum who's at the Atlantic has a
great quote about this where he says
every once in a while somebody takes the
rent money down to the dog track and
wins that doesn't mean that you should
take the money down to the dog track
right there are things that will happen
in the next four years that will be
positive for the next three years I'll
be positive that doesn't mean that the
solution to international diplomacy is
to basically make fun of all the other
leaders on Twitter that's not a strategy
and by the way making fun of leaders on
Twitter is not necessarily intrinsically
a undiplomatic approach you could have
both of the things we're talking about
you could have the madcap saber-rattling
tweets as part of a tool kit embedded in
a strategic process informed by
expertise yes that's not what's
happening well yeah I was gonna say this
the suspicion is that that's not the
case isn't it
there's been more BBC about it I would
love to have close to you hear that
actually Donald Trump's tweets are being
secretly drafted by a corps of experts
at the state but in a sense that was
actually I mean it's certainly something
we sort of in those days after he was
elected and when he went on tweeting and
there was a kind of sense was well maybe
he's on maybe this is all part of a plan
it's all worked out and it's good cop
bad cop with Tillison although you know
he was eventually given the heave-ho and
all the rest of it but actually no oh no
oh no no Ronan
you are an investigative journalist tell
this group of people is it a true or B
false that the Russians have something
on him that they're holding back I would
be disclosing nothing new to say that
there are sources in the intelligence
community leaking all over to the press
that they have intercepted
communications suggesting that
sorts of unsavory characters have
various pieces of material that could be
held over the president and certainly
one of the reasons why I have over the
last several months been doing reporting
that has exposed these secret election
season payments to suppress stories
several of them undertaken through the
intermediary of the National Enquirer
and its parent company American media
incorporated is because that has real
national security import for the reason
you suggested we have these sources
within these companies that are
essentially in the business of blackmail
and leverage acquiring dirt to hold it
over people commanding power over
considerable secrets that the president
has sought to keep out of the press and
the question we have to pose to
ourselves as a nation is do we feel
comfortable with those parties exerting
that influence over a sitting president
it's really quite unprecedented not I
have no information that doesn't have
obviously but you know it would not be
unlikely that will will come of this is
that there was a lot going on and Trump
knew very little or nothing about it the
question is what are we left with
afterwards not only in terms of the
presidency but also in terms of the
press and when you say a lot going on
you're talking about the collusion that
is or connections like feelers or
whatever pre-election yeah yeah but but
what's one thing that's frustrating for
me is to see the press being put in the
position again of rerunning Watergate
and which is essentially an
infantilizing
experience but a necessary one in this
moment because suddenly there's power
out there power is bad things are not
complex we know what the enemy is like
and so if you spend a lot of time
flipping between MSNBC and Fox and the
rest you do feel a bit that it's
kindergarten again not that the stakes
aren't very very high and not
the reporters aren't intelligent but
it's I feel it set us back that there
had been a learning process after
Watergate in the press and especially
after 9/11 that things are more complex
right and a little more boring and
necessarily boring once again we have
this high drama where a lot of things
are going to be beneath the radar
one more point to this question of what
influence foreign parties have over this
presidency you know and I think this
figures into the reporting question you
know are we doing enough to scrutinize
this the deep professionalizing of
American diplomacy and the cutbacks were
talking about and the orders that have
been given by members of this
administration and members of the Trump
family from for instance Jared Kushner
saying he didn't want experts and
diplomats in the room when he met with
the Chinese ambassador from Donald Trump
jr. during meetings with the Russians
where again you didn't have any kind of
professional expertise in the room one
of the consequences of that that I think
we haven't fully reckoned with is that
there is more room for outside
manipulation the reason we haven't
historically allowed those kinds of
meetings to proceed without experts in
the room is the other side can say
whatever they want about what happened
this has removed a layer of armor when
it comes to these corruption and
influence issues I was just gonna add
two about this question about blackmail
I think there's there's an astonishing
revelation that's come out in the last
36 hours which is that a Russian
oligarchs firm has paid a fun allegedly
paid into a fund of Michael Cohen
Trump's attorney right now to me that
solves the question about blackmail they
had damaging information they had
information that the Russian affiliate
oligarchy affiliated with the Kremlin
had paid the Trump's personal wire and
we just found out about it through this
payment happened a long time ago and
that's exactly what this question was
about about these alleged tapes in
Moscow was that they would know
something the public didn't and they
would have it over him well they did and
we know that and I think for the
collusion question I mean to me that the
Trump Tower meeting you couldn't have
written it I mean if you if you wrote
this email you
have believed it it says it's on behalf
of the top level sources in the Russian
government as part of our attempt to
help mr. Trump win and the responses I
love it when can we set up the meeting
Trump then announces himself within one
hour of the confirmation of that meeting
that he has new dirt on Hillary Clinton
I mean I I it baffles me how that is not
the answer that people believe that this
is a witch-hunt
when they've literally said we're with
the Russian government we're offering
you dirt on your opponent and they say
when can we meet that to me that
disqualifies you from being president
and also is a clearly attempted
collision with the Russian government
however I would I would add a dissenting
note and that is just because I do keep
up with the New York Times as much as I
can stand the experience of reading
about Trump all day long and I am weary
of the emphasis in the press on the
Russia element and I'm especially
impatient with the Democrats and
left-leaning media getting stuck on
trying to D would utilize the election
it's a little bit like trying to rewind
the tape and you know that didn't what's
let's go to the parallel universe in
which Donald Trump was not elected and
you'll see the same thing has been
happening over here with the Cambridge
analytical stuff that there's a there
are a lot of people in the remain camp
who are trying to do chittim eyes the
the referendum you know you were
misinformed you didn't know what you
were voting for etcetera and it's it's
running in place and I I think we just
have to deal with it you know Trump did
win the election so what are we gonna do
about it how are we gonna win the
midterms etc right so I think there's
two aspects I mean III agree with you
completely that there's a very large
wing of the Democratic Party that is
obsessed with me running the election
for me the reason why I think this story
is important is forward-looking it's
twofold one is how do we secure our
elections going forward and the second
thing is if a president is willing to
put himself in that compromised position
and is willing to get overtures from
Russian intelligence and that person is
in charge of our national security
that's a problem and so I think that
there is a
real issue here that's not about
relitigated 2016 it happened he was
elected but it's forward-thinking and
saying is our national security at risk
and is our election integrity at risk at
risk and I think both those seem to be
yes and that brings us very nicely to
domestic America which after all is
where these things are most closely
fought and I want Brian if I come
straight back to you because you you
have made a study of despots and you are
not making the case are you that Trump
is a despot
oh are you know so my book is called the
despots apprentice and it's very clearly
said as apprentice because I refer to
him as an authoritarian populist or a
wannabe despot somebody who has the
impulses of an authoritarian but exists
in the democratic system and the reason
I say that is because effectively the
difference is there are institutional
checks and balances that stop Trump from
doing things he would like to do but if
you look at the the pattern I mean my my
PhD was studying authoritarians I've
interviewed many authoritarians around
the world the pattern is striking
scapegoating minorities attacking the
press climbing them the enemy of the
people violating ethics rules calling to
jail your opponent violating rule of law
and saying that the norms are such that
you can fire investigators and the most
striking moment to this was parallel I
think is the 2013-14 investigation into
President Erdogan and Turkey where he
called the investigation of witch-hunt
he fired the prosecutors he said he was
a victim of the deep state and then he
purged the judiciary now this sounds
familiar and I think that the the the
factor of the fact that we still live in
a democracy is great but the fact that
we have a demagogue in the Oval Office
who has authoritarian instincts is
important and that's what I have it
although I read part of your book and
one of the things I liked about it is
that you didn't call him a demagogue
specifically you said he had these
characteristics and but one of the
things I appreciated about your
perspective is it's moderation and
wonder when the casualties of this
calamity has been to drive the
mainstream media into a constant
hyperbole I mean there was a while there
that the the headlines they were they
were spitting they couldn't they
couldn't top themselves they were so you
know world about to end and
there's a world ending a second day and
and now it's going to be the moon to it
it he likes that that's the point
doesn't it at that but it drives them to
be trumpian right act Liam that's one of
the problems we have I couldn't agree
with you more
is that part of the perversity of this
situation is that the press has to play
some kind of role in this but the role
that's been scripted for it is such that
it will simply heighten the anger that
led to this populist revolution because
the press has become an adversary of
whoever is in power it sees everything
in black and white now on both sides and
it simply feeds this sense that everyone
is corrupt in politics that our
institutions cannot be trusted that
nothing is fair and that just feeds the
source of populism that's more
significant far more significant on the
right in the country but could very well
come from the left is American freedom
genuinely Ronen under threat from this
man I think certainly every journalist I
know working today feels acutely
concerned about the kind of
authoritarian rhetoric that Brian just
described this is a hallmark of regimes
that seek to drive a wedge between the
public and those seeking to inform the
public there is a reason that the press
is the only profession constitutionally
protected in explicit terms in the
United States if you want to hold the
powerful accountable you need a vibrant
free press and I have been tremendously
encouraged to see how brave reporters
have banged their heads against the wall
trying to expose hard truths during this
era but the fact that it is in the midst
of an all-out rhetorical assault and
that there is a a siloing and deepening
partisanship in the media that is
separating people from the truth and
breeding distrust is troubling it's the
the rhetorical assault isn't it so their
rhetoric Lhasa you still have your
rights and you still have the First
Amendment et cetera etc but if nobody
believes anything and you see it
sometimes in Russian propaganda that
sometimes it's said of it
actually they're not intending that you
believe it they're just intending that
you get angry and confused and I just
wonder whether that has a genuine effect
when it comes from the Trump White House
yeah so I think it very much does and
this is why even though there hasn't
been wholesale shutting down of press
outlets the culture of democracy is
basically built around a combination of
laws and norms and norms are like the
soft guard rails around democracy Trump
is breaking those and and I also use the
analogy of democracy like a sand castle
it's something where it takes a very
long time to perfect but it can be
washed away reasonably quickly and I
think that what's happening is you know
we are careening towards a moment in
which a significant proportion of the
u.s. population believes the press is
the enemy of the people that anything
reported in mainstream outlets is fake
because negative towards the president
that they think the judiciary is just a
bunch of Democrats I have to get them
and these things have lasting
consequences that's why even if Trump is
removed from office or if the Democrats
win the midterms there is a cultural
shift that is not in favor of democratic
norms I think that is a significant if
they don't think those things under Bush
now I can remember quite feisty
conversation I've been going to a Bush
rally in Ohio I think it was to say I'm
from the BBC and there you go around
America basically with my accent and
people are incredibly friendly I just
arrived I'm from the BBC and I spent you
know my whole eight years basically at
impersonating Hugh Grant with not in
every respect had that go for you
but you know so you go out so you go to
rural Ohio and you say you from the BBC
and I can remember then actually it was
a group of Republicans waiting in line
to see and quite I mean they're
very polite because they're American but
there was there's a fair bit of
hostility and I wonder whether so the
point I'm getting to is whether actually
the dam breaking and those people
getting their man into the White House
is a sense a part of democracy and a
part of democracy that was missing under
your system where it was always the same
corporate interests that won every
election this is what these people might
say every time and actually the bursting
of the dam has been a good thing for
American democracy boy that would be a
tough sell he'll be a tough sell well I
gave it a go okay well but in another
sense no I mean certainly there are
problems with democracy right it's a
kind of political regime that has limits
and characteristic faults and they're
being exploited right now but coming
back to the press question too on your
point the press is not only protected in
order to haul out those in power it's
also as Thomas Jefferson said they're to
create an informed citizenry right and
so the more the press simply pays a role
of shouting at those in authority if
it's the opposition party no one's doing
the job of informing the public all
right I agree I think one of the biggest
and potentially most lasting casualties
of this presidency is what has happened
to the mainstream press it has abandoned
any pretense of neutrality and so and
I'm not talking about not the editorial
pages but but the but the reporting and
and it's not just the times it's the
Washington Post it's all the cable news
they are unabashedly partisan in a way
they never used to be before of course
you always knew there were some leanings
but this is this is you know the conceit
is
that the Republic is in danger to its
we're in an existential crisis and you
don't have to obey to the old Ruth rules
anymore even the ones that that pertain
to your own professional yeah ESCA mommy
you look at CNN domestic where were the
flailing about in the middle that
suddenly they get the bit between their
teeth and there are a lot of people
presumably now I'm seeing their
ordinance figures recently but there are
a lot of people presumably who want that
stuff and and under the American system
particularly the broadcast system where
you have to give the people what they
want or a significant number well you
know the advertising have you a distaste
you feed them junk food they're gonna
want junk food yeah it's not like this
is a red meat if they want red meat if
you and if you're not feeding the red
meat then people will go off and several
different things in a way that I think
is quite intellectually lazy I think
that the long-form investigative
journalism happening at places like The
Washington Post right now is
extraordinary and indispensable and is
exactly the spirit of creating an
informed citizenry that we so
desperately need right now and those are
incredibly brave reporters producing
that work and I'm thankful for them
every day and moved as I see that every
day
that is real public service and it is
stronger than it's ever been conflating
that with lazy partisan shouting on
cable television is I think not grounded
in the reality of those two things there
are pernicious trends in media there is
the superficial and the crass and the
Craven and the partisan and the endless
repetition of the same surfacey
headlines on a dying medium like cable
news but that has nothing to do with the
quality of reporting happening right now
mark if America decides it has had
enough of Donald Trump how does it get
rid of him in other words how do the
Democrats deal with not just the
midterms that are coming very soon
November this year but also of course
crucially with 2020 well the first thing
it has to do is to digest what has
happened and not run away from it and
not act as if we can run the tape back
as lie
set and to measure the kind of loss that
Democrats suffer and to see that this is
the culmination of a much longer process
that right now for example Republicans
control two-thirds of the governorships
in the United States they control
two-thirds of the legislative branches
in the states Republicans control
twenty-five states outright were they to
win a couple more they could call a
constitutional convention and that would
mean real change deep change in America
so this loss has been coming right
Democrats have lost a presence in the
middle of America both geographically
and in the ideological sense we are now
a party of the two coasts we are both an
elite party and a minority party without
many people who have fewer and fewer in
between and so confronting that should
be job one for Democrats right now I
mean there's a fire to put out granted
but without some long-term thinking
about how from 1980 until the president
until the present the Democratic Party
lost what was this its base in really a
in working class mainly white voters but
if you if you if you accept that loss as
a Democrat and say actually it doesn't
matter now because we can put it
together people who are atheists people
who are keen on transgender rights
people who say and otherwise you can get
his entire rainbow coalition of people
people who like public transport always
used to amuse me when I was there that
peak for the keenest people on public
transport were often regarded as kind of
dangerous socialists particularly in
Florida Florida cities where they were
trying to get light rail involves anyway
you get this group of people and you
stick them all together and you say look
there's nowhere else to go at least for
every four years come together and vote
for the Democrat as president can that
work
not at all for a couple of reasons one
is that in the places where we would
need to get votes among likely voters
who are in the middle 75% of them are
white and Christian so that's the old
America that we need to convince but
more importantly one forget were too
obsessed with the presidency in the
States we forget that the states
themselves hold tremendous power under
our system so for example there's a
constitutional right for a woman to have
an abortion in America and there are
states where de-facto it is virtually
impossible for a woman to get an
abortion in America that's a scandal oh
and you know what they just passed in
Iowa yes now it's not there they have
passed a law in Iowa that you have to be
able that as soon as you can detect the
feel heartbeat you can't get an abortion
which means six weeks max most women
don't even know they're pregnant by them
that's right and so with that I think in
order to protect the right of a woman in
Iowa to have an abortion you must win
elections in Iowa to win elections in
Iowa you must convince Iowans who were
overwhelmingly white and belit
tasks of the Democratic Party right now
the brain trust of the party is to think
about that and to think about you know
long-term being present in all these
places we've abandoned now I also think
the Democratic Party has to decide what
else it believes aside from a minority
rights
I mean Democrats have been very vocal on
all these fronts and I think that that
position of backing minorities rights is
established but they need more content
to their platform and you know the truth
is we still have a massive crisis in
health care in in the United States that
the Affordable Care Act has not fixed
just on the level of say what it costs
we speak we spend 10,000 dollars per
person per year on health care and you
know the average family of four makes an
average of about fifty seven thousand
dollars forty thousand of that is going
to
health care I mean it's bad enough that
I don't think it's an exaggeration to
say that the escalating health care cost
you have the have the ability to implode
the American economy
it's an employment but the Democrats are
all over the place on this well I was
simply gonna ask you that because before
the election
it was Trump who said Big Pharma and
murderers it was Hillary Clinton saying
about the talks of course they're
Democrats should be brave for once and
say yes we do want a national health
care system yeah I just wanted to add
two quick points I mean one is I think
that one thing that I deeply agree with
mark on is that the Democrats need to
win if they want to change things for
for the way that they see see fit and
that's that's something I think that's
lost in American politics is that you
can win the argument and lose the
election and I think the 2018 election
is the most important election in modern
American history and the reason I think
that even more than 2016 is because
because Trump was this trial balloon in
2016 he was this person who you sort of
thought let's let's roll the dice with
him now we've seen what he is and if
he's if 2018 is a is a continuation of
Republican control of the House and
Congress all Republicans are just going
to double down on trumpism if there's a
rebuke to them they will reform the
party and I think that's massively
important the other thing I'll just
quickly add is that we also need
institutional reform the average margin
of victory in the 2016 House races the
435 races for house of representatives
in the Congress was 37.1%
now part of that is gerrymandering where
people politicians are able to pick
their districts and effectively draw the
lines themselves part of it is
demographic sorting which is something
that I think is very important to Mark's
argument where you cannot draw a
competitive district in San Francisco
and you cannot draw a competitive
district in Texas but that is destroying
our politics because if you're in a
district that's 70% Republican and 30%
Democrat the only incentive you have is
to back Trump no matter how much you
loathe him personally because you might
lose the primary but you'll never lose
the general election and the exact same
thing is true for the districts that are
80% Democrat and 20% Republican it's
polarizing the country and without that
long-term reform it's not Trump that's
the problem it's a simple
of it he's a symptom of it and we have a
long-term challenge to the democratic
system itself and we should make it
clear this year in the in the midterm
elections this year the whole of the
House of Representatives up again for
election as it is every two years and a
third of the Senate and at the moment
how many seats would the Democrats have
to win in the house - it's about 23 so
it feels doable and yet actually I doubt
any of you are completely confident that
it absolutely will were just an anecdote
on this question of sorting I found
recently online an advertisement for a
real estate firm in Texas and their line
is they're looking for people out of
state to move there and their
advertising message is are you tired of
living in a blue state you tired of
being surrounded by all them liberals
we'll come on guys and they're reaching
out around the country and apparently
there are copycats now yeah I think
there's a very real chance that for the
first time in a long time we may see the
next two election cycles turn out to be
foreign policy elections and I say that
because of just how extreme the
decimation of America's diplomatic
standing in the world is just how
extreme the ramifications of something
like withdrawing from the Iran deal
could turn out to be the signal that
sends to our allies the signal that
sends to North Korea and other rogue
states the fact that we are embarking
disarmed if you will of our experts in
our diplomats on these international
adventures that have such incredibly
high stakes and could so rapidly turn
into tinderboxes of conflicts gives me
great fear that this could become both a
real crisis on the ground and also a
political tool I think
Ronan's right because I mean you we're
all living in the same world and it's
it's a there's always this feeling that
within 24 hours everything could change
and of course that's always been true
really but now now it feels most
immediate and
you know we can make predictions about
what will happen in the midterms but who
knows what's going to happen from now to
then I have never had an a year and some
months passed more slowly in my life and
and so it that now seems that now seems
a long time from now but that then leads
to what I think should probably be the
final question actually before we get
thrown open to people and that is if
given all those things are true
what then either a name or a type of
person who should the Democrats choice
be to try to topple Trump after one term
is it obviously Brian Oprah Winfrey or
are the other candidates I very much
hope that we do not make that mistake I
think the idea of fighting and
unqualified celebrity with an
unqualified celebrity is foolish and I
think that there are many people in the
party in the Democratic Party who would
make fine presidents I think one one
thing that's worth highlighting is that
if you ask this question in the first
year of Bush's second term Barack Obama
was not a name that a lot of people knew
and there there are people who you know
will emerge as real candidates and I
think that that's how it should be
because you have a real competitive
process hopefully they will pick someone
who can stand up to Trump so solid
governor I mean is that the kind of
person who can do it or do it do they
need to look if we're talking about
personalities what person what person
should be running we've already lost and
why is that that's because what the
Democrats lack and the Republican Party
had from 1980 until 2016 was a picture a
vision of the country they wanted to
create if Democrats cannot look within
and figure out what that is that they
want to offer to the public it will not
matter who is there because even if that
candidate wins he or she will be
hamstrung in Congress and in the States
it will not matter until we have a
national narrative to offer Americans
again we will simply be playing this
game at every election trying to win by
one or two points and achieving nothing
in the end right look I just want to be
a part of Oprah's Book Club xand
contests and I want to get a car and I
want to be validated and I want to
believe in the power of positive
thinking I'm an investigative journalist
I can't handicap upcoming races good
answer okay let me throw it out we'll
take several at a time but maybe start
with just one just to kick us off and
next to number one I can see someone
with their hand raised so they are you
first dibs hello and first may I say
thank you is this working yeah to all of
you for such an insightful somewhat
frightening but very informative
discussion today my name is Carol Moore
I am a member of Democrats abroad UK I
am retired so I also work for Democrats
in Florida three or four months a year
and my point is to remember Democrats
have been winning elections over the
last 18 months that is because of
grassroots activity that we haven't seen
before that is because of anger and it
is also because we do have policies that
are positive on key issues like health
care like the economy like the inequity
in America today that will make a
difference if we can take that Congress
we only need 23 seats now and the
non-biased
advisors political analysts cook
reportin sacra port etc suggest that
we're on course to take 40 seats in
November it's not guaranteed I agree we
have to get the voters out there all
right but my question to the panel is
what else do we need to do to win in
November besides getting the grassroots
out which we're doing and getting good
candidates which we are also doing and
we haven't done in the past that's
absolutely true thank you yeah okay
that's specifically on that candidates
point
mark what I mean there it is a fact
isn't it that the Democrats have either
come very close to winning or have
actually won special elections what we
would call by-elections and another
contest there has been some movement
already but is that it when it comes to
it and the selection of candidates for
2018 and indeed beyond do they go down
the kind of range route so its horses
for courses it's people who suit
particular areas and specifically on
something like abortion or gun control
quite a wide range of views within the
party or do they double down and go for
the kind of well as you would say that
kind of single core message that you
take to the American people well I would
just be repeating myself as if I said
that you know the larger message has to
proceed simply a collection of causes
and issues and policy papers but what
does that mean in candidate selection
because that can't it candidates who who
understand that that either they they
have a larger message and right now the
Democratic Party is not generating that
or they have a story you know one of the
interesting people that I've met since
my book came out is a woman who runs an
association for the veterans of Iraq and
the Afghan Wars
she's now in New York she sent me an
email after my article came out saying I
want you to know that I'm the president
of this organization I did several tours
of duty
I'm LGBT but before anything I'm a
citizen thank you for your article I
heard from her about six months ago we
met for a drink she's running for office
in Illinois and if more and so she has a
story to tell so right now the Democrats
are looking desperately for veterans and
what's interesting is they're finding
them you know they're finding school
teachers doctors and they're finding
veterans they're finding people who look
more like the people who are going to
vote and speak a little more like them
that could be an advantage okay couple
more and oh yes there are plenty of
hands out stop by number three is it
yeah hello I just like to hear the
panelists answer the question in the
title cuz I don't think anyone really
that's that so I guess it is what
Trump's doing is it permanently damaging
or is Trump a fluke and after he's gone
in four or god forbid eight years you
know is is will things go back to normal
what do you think hold that thought
let's get a couple more as well yeah yes
right up there next to you
regardless of whether collision is
proven or not is there not damage done
as people are willing to defend or
dismiss such serious allegations simply
as a witch-hunt yeah okay the witch hunt
won and son over there yes I'd like to
ask the panel what they do to deal with
the religious right in America which is
clearly aligned itself with a lot of
Republican views and how do you change
that because the demographic that you're
talking about will be persuaded by their
preachers that they should follow a
certain route fascinating question the
religious right of course well from
recent surveys seem to have actually
doubled down on their support for Trump
even after the election and in spite of
all the allegations about his behavior
said he rather prettily in his BBC when
allegations Malad actually we haven't
talked about when we should also get to
Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer what the
allegations are because they are kind of
breaking almost around us now but take
any or all of those questions so that
the permanence first of all the
permanence of the damage done anyone got
a view on that so I would throw into the
mix on that look just looking at the
narrow band of America's presence in the
rest of the world and what I write about
in this book war on peace about the
destruction of diplomacy I promised you
that I would flog it hard guys
you've been treating a word there are
typically sides of the coin
one is that history tells us that when
you have a disastrous and it usually is
disastrous sidelining of diplomacy very
often what follows is a course
correction and that happened in the
George W Bush presidency where after the
disasters of Iraq we saw a refocusing on
diplomacy and development there and also
elsewhere in the world with things like
the six-party talks with North Korea
under Condoleezza Rice it happened in
the Obama administration where you had
this disastrous Afghanistan review
overtaken by celebrity generals where
diplomats were kind of forced out of the
room and then in the second term in just
a few short years you saw the Iran deal
the thaw in relations with Cuba the
Paris climate change accord so what that
teaches us I think is that with just a
couple of years of leadership that cares
about making peace and undertaking
large-scale diplomat diplomacy and
diplomatic endeavors you can turn things
around you can pull out of the nosedive
but the flip side of the coin I was
referring to is that the flow of talent
into American foreign policy and the
prestige and primacy of America around
the world is not something even turn
around overnight because the people who
should be on a track already to become
ambassadors in ten years and in 20 years
are no longer entering the systems and
and again and again you know you have
every former Secretary of State
expressing some degree of anguish about
the fact that even if we start now and
we need to urgently this will be years
of repair so I think the answer for
abroad is semi irreparable for domestic
sure so I have one of the final chapters
of my book is the ghost of despotism yet
to come and it's about you should buy
both
we're here the only reason I mentioned
this is because it's exactly this
question about the future and and I have
several scenarios but I'll mention three
of them one of them is a trump 2.0
figure where Trump is the forerunner
right where he he sort of lays the
groundwork for somebody who is just as
similar in Trump in terms of personality
and in terms of his sort of ability to
scapegoat minorities and really you know
throw red meats the Republican base but
smarter and doesn't tweet stupid stuff
all the time right that I think is a
very dangerous scenario the second one
is the possibility of just democratic
decay and this is just in very succinct
terms if you think about what I said
about democracy being a sandcastle
it's a lumpy mess right it's still a
democracy we're still okay but it's very
broken and I think that's where we're
heading right now well then that's where
you get to that any question over there
about about witch hunts that you're
actually at then does to your to your
are you pre-empting me because I was
going to work this into my third Stewart
so the third scenario this is this is
why I think November 6 2018 is so
critical is what I call the Trump
vaccine it's where it's where basically
there's a rebuke of Trump there's the
course correction round and talks about
and all of a sudden there's an ability
to rebuild the institutions that have
been under assault if you think that
everything that comes out of the press
is either a witch hunt or fake news and
the control of Congress retains Israel
is retained by the Republicans there are
going to be many years of people who
continue to parrot that narrative
narrative even more aggressively because
they just got told that's the way you
win elections and as soon as they learn
that I think we're in very dangerous
territory which is why I think the
answer to your question is watch what
happens on November 6 2018 if the
Republicans control all of Congress I
think we're in very deep trouble I think
if there's any movement where the
Democrats take the house I think it'll
be ok
the question about the Religious Right
is so fascinating isn't it yeah what on
earth is going on well I asked my
liberal students to take a guess of what
percent of the American public myself
identifies as evangelical and what
percent self identifies as transgender
the number of self-identified
evangelicals is twenty twenty percent
the percent of transgender people is one
third of 1% from democratic rhetoric you
would not guess that and it's not just a
question of Elections it's a question of
culture as well
we're undergoing now in the United
States and also many countries in the
developed world to revolution
simultaneously one is a political
revolution
it's populist and it's democratic the
other revolution is a cultural
revolution having to do with inclusion
and respect focused on minorities and on
women it's an enlightened revolution
Ronan has been an important figure in
this but it is elite driven no one gets
to vote on what they see on television
no one gets to vote on who gets cast in
shows in Hollywood or what they see on
their screens and so there is a
population in the United States of
people I would say religious southerners
in particular who never see themselves
represented in our media and until now
that's because of what's going on
culturally but it has political effects
and somehow the Democrats need to be
able to address this quite large group
in the population and make them
understand that we care about the health
and well-being of their families and
their communities and that the fact that
we're Democrats should not turn them off
Ronald Reagan once addressed a group of
evangelical ministers back before they
used to endorse candidates and he got up
and he said I know you can't endorse me
but I endorse you it's very difficult to
imagine a national figure in the
Democratic Party doing that before an
evangelical group but it's absolutely
not
Cerie and if you think of Jimmy Carter
which I mean that to me doesn't feel
like that long ago but I guess to her
people was a long time ago
are you seriously saying that there is a
chance again that the Democrats could go
back to a position where either through
the person of their candidate or at
least through an outreach they could
significantly make inroads into that
white evangelical vote again I think
they could particularly based on the
character of our current president we
are not we should be making a religious
appeal or values appeal that has abated
no we haven't done that with our leaders
we do not have people who are the
connective tissue between the
evangelical population in the United
States and generally the religious
population in the United States and our
party it's not there okay no questions
yeah lady yeah I was wondering if you
could touch upon the Supreme Court and
what Trump can be doing there the damage
that can do and maybe explain a bit the
importance of the Supreme Court in the
American government system yeah very
very good question or of course one of
the reasons why evangelicals did vote in
large numbers for Trump yeah down here
on my on my they went to ask about what
damage you thought Trump could cause to
America's legal culture and it's
reverence of it so it's legal culture
did yeah yep yeah miss driver in your
book we need to talk about Kevin and
also in an article for the independent
you discuss the issue of gun control to
what extent do you believe that this
will contribute to an even more
disunited states of america there you go
gun control first
well the gun control issue is one of the
big emotional dividing lines between
what we're calling Republicans and
Democrats but I think that the divide is
actually much more profound than party
allegiance it's between city and country
it's it's between the middle of the
country and the coasts and it has to do
with I mean we it's it's an overused
word but its identity right and I think
that's one of the reasons you can get
the evangelicals to go along with really
what should be putrid behavior for them
you know this kind of sexual stuff that
the the in with Trump that they should
deeply disapprove of but they have
identified with this group of people and
ownership of guns or at least the the
right to buy guns is part of that
culture it's a basket of beliefs and and
it runs very deep in these in it in
these areas because it has become
geographical not just not just political
and whereas you know the the blue states
the the coast the urban elite don't even
understand why anyone wants to own a gun
they they don't get it I've actually had
to go on the news before and explain it
to everyone I'm not sure I did a very
good job because I'm probably you know
I'm part of the coastal elite - and I
don't own a gun and I've never owned a
gun but I think that's that sometimes we
need to extend our imaginations is which
which is why I do four professionally -
what what what that means to people what
is it the what does the right of gun
ownership mean to these people and it
had I think it has fundamentally to do
with people who feel that agency has
been taken from them and gun ownership
is agency it's the it's the ability to
defend yourself
you get what you want if only by force
and to to if necessary even defy your
own government that's what it means so
it's not as simple as we just need to
buy to pass a bunch of laws and and
nobody will have guns anymore and we
won't have these horrible mass murders
it's it's it's very deep in the culture
on to the legal stuff
particularly I guess we should talk a
little bit about before we get to the
Supreme Court about the federal
judiciary you think at the moment you
were looking in you look at some of the
big things that Trump has wanted to do
and has been stymied doing them it is
the judges at the moment isn't it who've
stopped in does that carry on does he
get to appoint new ones what goes on
there so I think that this will be the
most lasting consequence of the Trump
administration is they are appointing a
huge number of federal judges at an
unprecedented pace I mean 16 appellate
court judges now and there's five more
in the wings which is which could
potentially transform the American
judiciary so the rule of law I think
though is is also under attack I mean I
think that there's a real attempt to
politicize rule of law by the Trump
administration and I think you know this
also speaks to the point about us
becoming trumpian in response to Trump
one of the things that struck me was he
had a tweet I think yesterday or two
days ago that said 13 Democrats are
investigating me right and and my
response to this on Twitter was
literally every single senior official
in the Russia investigation is either a
Republican registered appointed by
Republican or appointed by Trump or all
of the above now of course I'm right
about that but the problem is that
that's not what's important about them
what's important about them is that
they're public servants and we used to
think about people in that realm of the
law as public servants who were
appointed by Republicans and Democrats
both and had this ethos that the rule of
law was important and as a result of
that Trump is having an effect even when
people push back at him that deepens the
sense that the law is an instrument of
who's in power and that I think is very
dangerous in a democracy which takes us
then to that that is the question up
there can to can Trump in a sense
capture the supreme court
I mean there is going to be potentially
another pic isn't there so he came to PI
he picked someone who'd you can make a
case for saying was a perfectly
reasonable appointment actually
conservative appointment to the Supreme
Court no course not not trumpian in the
sense of being completely out of left
field and certainly a qualified lawyer
and all the rest of it and and but but
there if there is another pick is that
where things get sticky Ronin you know
here again I have to be careful about
what I say I did actually have a comment
following up on what Brian just said
which is about partisanship and the way
in which the media is both culpable for
the environment of partisanship that we
live in in the United States and also a
victim of that environment of
partisanship you know I spent the last
several months on back-to-back news
breaks about Donald Trump and these
secret payments and allegations of
corruption around them and each time I
broke one of those stories I would be
inundated with tweets saying but what
about the Democrats but what about Bill
Clinton and then you know I turn around
and break a story about someone like the
New York Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman and allegations of domestic
abuse against him and I'm inundated with
tweets saying well but what about Trump
what have you done for us on Trump
lately let's focus on Trump a little bit
you know and it's a remarkable
reflection of I think a conspiring of
cable news and algorithmically generated
Internet news that leads people to be so
siloed that literally these two groups
have not seen each other have not seen
the other stories are not talking to
each other and you can have you know
half of my reporting run wild
in the conservative blogosphere and half
of it run wild in liberal publications
and never the twain shall meet and it's
deeply deeply troubling to me as we
confront this whole range of issues that
we're talking in those circumstances the
Supreme Court becomes even more
important doesn't it yes and and
obviously one of the explicit functions
of the Supreme Court is to protect
against the tyranny of the masses
and to protect against the the most
vulnerable people in our country they
are specifically supposed to push back
against political pandering and be
insulated from that and so you know yes
this is one of the I mean there's no way
for me to get into predictions about
that without getting in hot water but
sir and I wouldn't trust my predictions
anyway you know there is seldom a way to
reliably predict that but I would say
that that is as pivotal an issue as we
face as we look at the potential
degradation of the rights of minorities
in America yeah all right do you wanna
say something else no no I'm gonna check
with you every time now before I go back
I have to stop we should be comforted by
the fact that even if there is another
opening since you concede that Gorsuch
is really not so bad that still leaves
eight people relatively sane so in the
whole nation numerically we're safe for
a time all right yeah hi I'm American
living in England for about 15 years
when I listen to this in my distress
about my wonderful country and I think
back I'm old enough to remember when
there was a campaign one television to
wear seatbelts and a campaign not the
litter and I think people were swayed I
remember having my great-uncle saying
I'll never wear a seat belt over my dead
body I'll never wear a seat belt
and I think how scared are the people
that are patriots in our country on the
Democratic Party and the Republican
Party to make a stand about crucial
issues whether it's gun control or
health care about prison reform going
through a list and and why aren't those
Republicans and Democrats who are scared
to speak up for whatever reason that's
going on in our country because I feel
both parties are really not doing the
job that we want them to do okay
Patriots speaking up yeah right right up
at the back okay yeah
Brit big supporter of the USA I I
you've covered what it says on the tin
to be honest but what I'd like to know
is how Trump is preparing to be the
second economy in the world when the
Chinese overtake them in two three four
years and I think that's you know
something that's very serious he's
pissing off the Chinese to some extent
and where does he go from there yeah
okay transformation over China that's
that's a good one one more down yeah
what do you think we love Saudi Arabia
is in all of this
so the trumpeting out of the Iran deal
yesterday I can't help but think it
gives Saudi Arabia a stronger pretext
for a nuclear weapons program and
remitting the lines of Jared Kushner
and MBS last year and indeed the dossier
it's difficult to avoid the idea that
Saudi Arabia where a nuclear weapons
program is part of the plan what role do
you guys think Saudi Arabia plays and do
you think that some their influence in
the world and foreign affairs is
outweighs geography basically yeah you
know Obama turned up to the when the
king of Saudi Arabia died Obama was
there within 24 hours so as Prince
Charles there's no other country that
kills gays and and and you know
basically it's pretty dastardly so the
vast majority of people that has people
like a barber turning out for funerals
could a barber have been tougher on
Saudi Arabia could Trump be tougher and
is there an ally that America has really
that's stronger a more influential than
Saudi Arabia Ronan so I'll take two of
those questions was about the rising
influence of China and it's important to
talk about all that we've said about the
erosion of American foreign policy might
in the context of you know not the UK or
Germany
heaven forfend filling the space but
China you have Beijing nipping at our
heels in each of these areas sending you
know envoys to do shuttle diplomacy
where we no longer have ambassadors
doing large-scale infrastructure
projects where we have cut all of our
USAID funding so we're very rapidly
seeing a world in which China dominates
not just economically but also in terms
of soft power and I think we should all
be troubled for the reasons that this
second
question touched on you know despite all
of the United States foibles and its
troubles as a force for human rights in
the world it is still a nation that
prioritizes those issues to an extent
that Beijing does not and that may
change over time but right now I think
it is worth scrutinizing what a
china-led soft power center of gravity
looks like
likewise you know I think that the
erosion of our reliance on experts and
long-term strategic thinkers has
exacerbated our military-to-military
relationships in places like Saudi
Arabia and you see you know at times
when crackdowns on freed basic freedoms
in places like Saudi Arabia and also at
times when Saudi Arabia is a malign
influence in places like Yemen where one
of the worst humanitarian catastrophes
in the world is playing out we
nevertheless are doubling down on arms
deals and I think that is because we
have an unrestrained center of power
occupied by the military in our
policymaking and the voices that are
supposed to advocate for human rights
concerns and the long term costs of
those transactional relationships just
don't get hurt too often fine yeah I'll
actually focus on those two questions as
well briefly with the rise of China I
think one thing that's really striking I
do a lot of research in sub-saharan
Africa parts of the Middle East
Southeast Asia China is winning a lot of
the argument about what model we should
follow and there's a lot of even chinese
state media is explicitly pointing to
trump and dare i say also brexit as
reasons why the Western democratic model
has failed and it's created
self-inflicted wounds now whether you
agree with that or not that is
persuasive to a certain group of
countries who say we don't need
elections we don't need democracy we
just need growth now what's actually
happening because Trump is withdrawing
American diplomacy from those areas and
America first I would argue is more
America alone is that you have an
instance where China is actually making
serious inroads in those places peeling
off partnership
and the world is going to be shaped
increasingly by China I think that's
something that we have not thought about
as a forward-thinking country planning
for 2030 2040 in terms of Saudi Arabia I
think one thing I would add to to the
question is the first foreign visit that
Trump made was to Saudi Arabia it's the
first time put in post-world War two
history that the u.s. President did not
make their first foreign visit to a
Western democracy and Trump did a sword
dance after attacking journalists with a
regime that the heads dissidents with
sorts
that's a striking message as a striking
image and I think that the US has a lot
to own up to not just Trump with its
relationship with Saudi Arabia but the
combination of these soft power dynamics
is going to have real change for the
world and I think one of the saddest
things about Trump is he captured these
people who feel left behind by a
changing world and he's not thinking
about how it's changing he's his answer
is not about inequality that's going to
happen it's inequality that happened
through trade the real challenges
Automation China is thinking about that
we're not and I think that's why we have
a really stupid and counterproductive
foreign policy going forward
that's going to catch up to us in the
next few years
well if I'm gonna step back and be big
picture from once and also promote one
of my books yeah my last one of my books
my wife's novel is called the mandibles
and it's set in 2029 and it it foresees
a dire future for my country and I'm
afraid that future it had with the
election of Donald Trump got a little
more possible that novel focuses on the
economic collapse of the country because
of such high levels of debt and his
policies so far are only only
accelerating that debt now I am a great
and this thing on such a big downer but
I am concerned that we may be looking at
the decline of the American Empire and
uh and and Trump is hurrying it along
there are a lot of elements that look
bad and that including environmental and
economic and and political I think the
you know not just the presidency but
Congress has been breaking down
increasingly incapable of passing
legislation and addressing the issues of
the country and I I think that our
ability to elect Trump makes the country
look bad and has emboldened our
competitors like China and it's had the
larger effect of basically the you pull
back the curtain and the The Wiz The
Wizard of Oz is just a fat man with an
orange face I know that note ladies and
gentlemen we have reached Harper State
it's time to finish
applause please for them all
[Applause]
and also for you thank you so much for
coming